ja ich sag mal so robert habeck hat mich
leicht irritiert oder ich war
erschrocken es ist geplant strom
gas aus katar
ist die frage ist es die richtige
entscheidung wie wir alle wissen wir
sind abhängig von fossilen
energieträgern wie kohle putin gas und
öl wir wissen genau diese ressourcen
sind begrenzt was wiederum zu resultat
für das explodierende strom und energie
preise gibt die frage die wir uns
stellen sollten wie schaffen wir es eine
kluge und saubere klimapolitik zu
gestalten ohne gleichzeitig auf den
wohlstand zu verzichten bzw zu gefährden
kurzfristig habe insbesondere
langfristig ich sage saubere energie aus
der wüste desertec die vision von
desertec ist vor 15 jahren ins leben
gerufen und wurde von der politik bisher
nicht ausreichend unterstützt nun ist
die zeit dazu reicht definitiv die
lösung großflächige wind und
solaranlagen in der wüste bevorzugt in
nordafrika der transport der generierten
energie erfolgt über unterwasserkabel
über stromtrassen oder per schiff wir
haben ausreichend frei verfügbare
flächen in den wüsten um den kompletten
energiebedarf der erde zu lösen bzw zu
decken
deutschland und europa muss endlich
aufwachen schauen wir nach china in
china entstehen derzeit 450 gigawatt an
wind- und solarkraftwerken das
entspricht in etwa 400 atomkraftwerken
das heißt china macht sich komplett
unabhängig von energieimporten aber auch
von fossilen energieträgern will
deutschland und europa dem wettbewerb
erneut hinterher rennen
ich sage nein ich sage setzt auf strom
aus der wüste macht euch machen wir uns
gemeinsam unabhängig ich habe kürzlich
gelesen ein journal aus amerika sagte
[Musik]
deutschland macht weltweit die
schlechteste energiepolitik lieber herr
beck das sollten wir ändern ich stehen
mit rat und tat zur seite
der kniefall waren das den aktiv aber
robert habeck ist natürlich auf
schwieriger mission und die misere mit
der erst jetzt zu tun hat die hat viele
mütter und väter das sind natürlich die
die nur über ausstieg reden geredet
haben in den letzten jahren ob bei kohle
oder atom da waren die grünen dabei aber
natürlich auch viele andere die zu große
abhängigkeit von russland da waren viele
dabei das falsch einzuschätzen
und atomkraft wurde beschleunigt der
ausstieg da haben wir viel zu tun und
die optionen die sie genannt haben die
wohnt so wenig verfolgt also
technologieoffenheit und die sonst so
viel gerühmte vielfalt also hier auch
diversifizieren bei den energieträger
dass es sträflich vernachlässigt worden
aber da waren waren die grünen nicht die
einzigen die ihren anteil daran haben
und robert habeck muss jetzt in kurzer
zeit dafür sorgen dass wir alternativen
finden insofern ich würde mich so hart
verurteilen aber die energiepolitik der
letzten jahre die ist gescheitert ich
würde ihnen noch schärfer vorurteilen
also wahrscheinlich jeder hier weil ich
finde das müssen wir machen es
wahrscheinlich zu sagen aber ich denke
es ist drin ich darüber rede wie schlimm
ist es was er haben mit katar lassen wir
doch einmal herrn farbig erklären warum
er dir ein video aufgenommen mit einem
land wie katar jetzt geschäfte machen
möchte die menschenrechte werden da ja
nicht so richtig gewagt aber hören wir
doch mal wieder herr h becks worten
klingt das ist natürlich eine politisch
sagen wir interessante region das nicht
immer angesprochen habe sind die arbeits
und menschenrechte die natürlich ein
großes thema sind es gibt nur 300.000
kataris zehn prozent der bevölkerung
drei millionen menschen leben hier der
rest arbeitet hier häufig nicht so ganz
guten bedingungen die
arbeits und menschenrechte in katar die
diskussion ist uns bekannt sagt er über
die fußball-wm reden das ist das halte
ich auch nicht für relevant sondern ich
mir wird es ein bisschen schwierig wenn
wir dabei sind ein politisches risiko
russland durch ein anderes politisches
risiko arabische länder einzutauschen da
kann jeden tag an politischer umsturz
stattfinden in den emiraten aber auch in
nordafrika kein staat ist demokratisch
sicher und verlässlich und ich finde wir
sollten aus dem ausland abenteuer
insofern lernen dass wir uns bei den
energie importen ausschließlich auf dem
und zwar auf sauber regierte
demokratische staaten verlassen da sind
die usa kanada australien
europa natürlich
und ansonsten sollte man die finger
davon lassen vielleicht kleinere mengen
die nicht maßgeblich sind für unsere
gesamtversorgung aber das sollten wir
gelernt haben und damit bringen wir es
auch zusammen ich weiß nicht ob wir
nicht in zehn jahren komisch aus der
wäsche gucken wenn das was sie oft in
der bücher aufgebaut haben von
irgendwelchen islamisten ab gekappt wird
die dort die macht übernommen ich sage
ja desertec steht für sauberen
wüstenstrom für europa wäre natürlich am
besten nordafrika aber es gibt ganz
andere wüste atacama wüste in chile da
gibt es ein pilotprojekt von volkswagen
porsche siemens gemeinsam mit enel dem
energieversorger aus italien die
machenden pilotprojekt um die flut zu
generieren also es ist nicht zwingend in
nordafrika
limitiert da der mittlere osten macht
sehr genau so da sind wiederum die
chinesen involviert shanghai electric
baut gemeinsam mit dem saudi-arabischen
aqua energieversorger dort genau das was
wir schon seit jahren fordern ja das ist
die unabhängigkeit und man kann zwar
transportieren man kann wasserstoff
generieren und die politische
instabilität ist was sie gerade sagen
widerspreche ich tunesien marokko
überall macht man urlaub russland hat
man jahrelang sag ich mal unterstützt
dreimal in maria konnte man vom halben
jahr schon keinen urlaub mehr machen im
november kreise bald die diplomatischen
beziehungen quasi eingefroren waren weil
sich deutsche touristen da gar nicht um
ungehindert aufhalten konnten also das
ist abhängig aber auch hier reden
vergabe jeder rolle was alles nicht geht
wir haben auch in den letzten jahren
viel zu viele über ausstiege in
deutschland geredet und nicht wo wir neu
einsteigen soll ich doch grund dazu dazu
gehört auch eine gehörige portion
antiamerikanismus weil nämlich zum
beispiel das thema flüssiggas sehr früh
generell verteufelt wurde jetzt heißt es
plötzlich terminal wird gebaut für lg
flüssiggas es bis vor kurzem immer
blockiert worden und übrigens nicht
zuletzt auch mit dem argument mag sein
dass es teuer ist es ist auch aufwendig
aber im verhältnis dazu von wem wir uns
sonst abhängig machen und wenn man dann
mal wieder die gretchenfrage stellt
rufen wir an wenn wir schutz brauchen
wir probleme haben in moskau oder in
washington dürfte die antwort klar sein
trotzdem haben wir wurde über jahre
mehrheitlich ausgeschlossen dass
flüssiggas überhaupt ein teil unserer
energieversorgung sein kann so sich aus
dieser illusion und aus dieser naivität
wachen jetzt viele auf das wichtigste
ist die unabhängigkeit des kids
hauptsächlich deutschland und europa
muss sich unabhängig machen die wikinger
kinder macht er jetzt die macht sich
komplett unabhängig oder einfach ein
großes aber nicht von denen die eine
bedrohung sind die amerikaner hatten
doch auch recht damit indirekt jetzt ist
das große thema bei uns dass wir
natürlich über diese fossilen
energieträger sehr wohl die aufrüstung
finanzieren in russland also da war ja
was dran während wir gleichzeitig die
zwei prozent in der nato nicht einhalten
als deutschen also diese dieser ärger in
amerika der übrigens nicht nur was mit
trump zu tun hatte sondern über alle
politischen lager hinweg über
deutschland und europa gab es da unmut
in amerika der war ja nicht unberechtigt
aber letztendlich haben wir immer noch
keine schnelle lösung es gibt tolle
ideen und tolle erfindungen liegen auf
den türstock gerade was den wasserstoff
angeht hat das level ist ja genau schon
vor 20 jahren bin ich da shuttle service
mit bmw abgeholt worden warum ist es so
leise ja der ist mit wasserstoff
betrieben aber die lobbyisten die haben
sich einfach durchgesetzt sie wollten
weiter eben benzin und öl und
verbrennungsmotor und und da konnten die
sich damit nicht durchsetzen aber die
ganzen pläne davon liegen seit vielen
jahren in den schubladen
aber das jetzt so schnell zu aktivieren
so schnell wie wir es brauchen dass es
eben das puzzle sind zum teil sehr
schnell kohle können sie sofort in
australien kaufen öl und gas kann man
aus der nordsee bekommen von
verschiedenen ländern darf man nicht so
viel kriegen in norwegen gab es gerade
ein erdbeben weil die sehr viel gas aus
der erde holen das ist für die zum teil
das seismologische gefährlich darf nicht
zu viel sein aber ich wiederhole noch
mal usa kanada europa austragen
politik zurück man muss endlich auch mal
sehen was vorgehen wäre 23 aus japan
haben die börsen aber jedenfalls das ist
ein zweitrangiges argument weil wir
müssen los von russland und wir müssen
russland sehr viel stärker sagen zu als
bisher tun darum energie
ich weil die entsorgung nicht geklärt
ist um es klar zu sagen und die wird
auch nicht geklärt werden wir noch fünf
jahre verlängern dagegen habe ich im
prinzip nichts wenn man das brauchen
aber die entsorgungsfrage ist immer noch
offen und sie es überall oft ist es
irgendwo geklärt und es ist auch nicht
billig und es gibt zum beispiel wenn wir
uns da ja ein beispiel an china zum
beispiel nehmen das habe ich beim
letzten mal schon angelegt aber keiner
kannte sich scheinbar damit aus das ist
die sind diese thorium reaktoren die in
china entwickelt werden das sind
reaktoren die eigentlich ähnlich
funktionieren wie ein kernkraftwerk aber
sie sind viel kleiner und produzieren
viel viel weniger atommüll und vor allen
dingen das was man dazu braucht das
kriegen wir alles hier aus unserem boden
wir brauchen keine tolle seltenen erden
kaufen oder irgendwas es ist eine
preiswerte und
relativ umweltfreundliche energie
versorgung die man vielleicht einsetzen
könnte bis man wirklich
alles andere technisch so auf den stand
gebracht haben uns fehlen einfach nur
die wissenschaftler die sitzen in china
die sitzen sonst wo die sind jetzt schon
wieder schneller als wir gibt es ja viel
in deutschland beim ernst die sind alle
stillgelegt worden weil alle
reaktorlinien es gibt plötzlich wie sie
zurecht an ganz verschiedene atomare
entwicklungslinien die sind alle
eingestellt worden also wir waren ja zum
teil auch bei kleinen kugelhaufen
reaktoren und anderen weniger
gefährlichen reaktor typen sie sind zum
teil schon hier gebaut worden im versuch
uns alles vorbei ich war könnte man
wieder aktiviert hat man schon aber wohl
nennt man den müll hin das ist die
ungeklärte falls das ist ungeklärte
frage aber man kann nicht darauf von
ausgehende motoren bei müll hin und
schaltet
atom abgeschaltet kohle ab und hat keine
alternativen nämlich von ich bin hier
für sie also insofern recht dass man die
noch bestehenden kernkraftwerke um drei
jahre verlängert da sagen alles geht gar
nicht viel zu teuer und so weiter wenn
man es braucht muss man es tun der
meinung bin ich nach wie vor in afrika
entstehen 900 kohlekraftwerke in
südostasien
5000 sollen entstehen kohlekraftwerke
ich sage immer klimawandel hört nicht an
der deutschen außengrenze auf also und
muss zielgerichtet überlegen wie kann
man es lösen und entweder es nur die
zwei varianten weltweit dafür kennen
stehe ich und kämpfe darauf höre auch
entweder atomenergie oder wüstenstrom es
gibt nur die zwei varianten und dann es
gibt die grünen ja auch wenn wir dann
den dient atomenergie aus den
nachbarländern kaufen oder von ländern
wo die reaktoren nicht so sicher sind
wie bei uns dann und für teures geld
dann bringt das ja auch nicht wir
brauchen schon alternativen weil
letztendlich ist die kernenergie nicht
des pudels kern und die beste lösung wir
sollten schon das irgendwie eliminieren
irgendwann aber es gibt alternativen wir
müssen uns einfach nur man muss auch
kaufmännisch denken die strompreise
explodieren die energiepreise im
allgemeinen und warum explodieren die
weil wir eine höhere
eine höhere nachfrage haben und das
angebot fällt das ist ja schlichtweg der
punkt und mit wüstenstrom können wir
zumindest das angebot erhöhen also was
in der deutschen debatte über die frage
der energiepreise unterversorgung nicht
öffentlich mit diskutiert wird ist ja
die frage liebe nena da du immer sagst
was kostet das dann ist die frage woher
man momentan die preise auch nähen woher
man ich bin ja kein nebenfach nadja
ist die frage das ist abschalten von
gasversorgung zur heizung von wohnungen
sich überhaupt nicht stellt weil nach
den geltenden deutschen gesetzen die
wohnungen bis zum schluss versorgt
werden und das ist ungefähr ein drittel
das des des bedarfs und dann kommt die
industrie obendrauf die allerdings ist
dann jener branche ist die gefährdet
wenn an den gas- abgeschaltet wird aber
das sagt ja sogar herbeck bis zum
jahresende haben wir gar kein problem
also bis zum nächsten winter warum sagt
dieses land nicht ich rede jetzt über
sanktionen gegen russland warum ist
dieses land nicht in der lage zu sagen
wir steigen jetzt aus und üben maximalen
druck auf butt hinaus und sagen bis zum
nächsten winter das schaffen wir den
satz haben wir schon mal gehört ich
glaube auch das können wir schaffen